الان مشاهدينا الى متابعه ما بات يعرف
بحرب الرقائق اذ حفت الصين هولندا على
الانضمام اليها فيما سمتها جهود الدفاع عن
التجاره الحره ياتي ذلك بعد ابرام
الولايات المتحده صفقه مع هولندا واليابان
لتقييد صادرات بعض الات تصنيع الرقائق
المتقدمه الى الصين وقالت بلومبر ان
الاتفاقيه ستوسع من مدى ضوابط التصدير
التي اعتمدتها الولايات المتحده في اكتوبر
لتشمل الشركات الموجوده في الدولتين
الحليفتين بموج ستظل الشركات اليابانيه
والهولنديه قادره على بيع المنتجات غير
المتقدمه للصين ويمكن لتلك الشركات تغطيه
اي تراجع في الشحنات التي كانت تباع في
الصين من خلال زياده التصدير الى مناطق
مثل الولايات المتحده والمانيا والهند
ماذا تفضل معنى من لندن زاك ميرز كبير
الباحثين في مركز الاصلاح
الاوروبيه سيد مياز
لماذا تركيز الولايات المتحده على هذا
النوع من الصناعات يعني الرقائق المتقدمه
ومحاوله الحد من تصديرها الى الصين حتى من
دول حليفه ليس من الولايات المتحده دول
حليفه كهولندا مثلا
المتحده سياسه للحد من قدره الصين الى
الوصول الى او الى تعزيز هذا القطاع ما
حصل في اكتوبر من العام الماضي هو ان
الولايات المتحده قررت ان تسرع او ان تعزز
هذه القيود بحيث تغطي
جزءا اكبر من الات تصنيع هذه الرقائق احد
الاسباب الرئيسيه هو ان الولايات المتحده
اكتشفت ان الصين نجحت في تصنيع رقائق
متقدمه مما كانت تطيح له القيود السابقه
كذلك ترى الولايات المتحده ان الصين تتقدم
سريعا في الاسلحه المتقدمه مثل
الصواريخ
فائقه فائقه للصوت ويمكن للصين ان تقود في
مجره مثل ذكاء الاصط وهذا يعطي الصين اذا
افضليه على الغرب والولايات المتحده
بالنسبه الى طلب الولايات المتحده
للمساعده من هولندا هولندا واليابان وقت
متحده تشكلاني 90% من السوق العالميه
لالات تصنيع هذا الرقائق المتقدمه
وبالتالي سيكون صعبا على الولايات المتحده
لوحدها ان تمنع او تقيد قدره الصين على
التقدم فعلا التكنولوجيا بدون انضمام
اليابان وهولندا اليها هولندا على وجه
الخصوص مهمه في هذا المجال لانه لديها
شركه اي اس امل التي تعتبر المنتج العالم
التي تصنع همم دائره واحده اساسي من تصنيع
هذا الرقائق الالات التي تصنعها ايسام
عاليه اكثر تقدما من اي مكان في العالم
اذا لو وصلت الصيل الى هذا على الالات اي
زياده اسهل عليها ان تتقدم سريعا في مجال
تصنيع الرقائق
في ظل هذه القيود التي تضعها الولايات
المتحده وتشمل الان همم وقف الصادرات من
هولندا واليابان الى اي مدى هذا سيضر
بصناعه الرقائق في الصين وهل الصين قادره
على الالتفاف على ذلك
هي ليست شامله اي انه يمكن الالتفاف حولها
الى درجات معينه كما اسلفت همم صدمت
المتحده لرؤيه الصين تنتجه هذا نوع من
الرقائق بالرغني من وجود الكثير من القيود
على وصولها الى هذا النوع من التكنولوجيا
ولكن حتى الان وجد الطريق لاستخدامه
وتسخيري وسائل وادوات اخرى للتقدم
والغرب
انه يمكن ان الداعيه ان هذا القيود
الجديده من شانها فعلا ان تقييد قدره
الصناعه التقدم ولكنها ستكون فعاله احد
همم
جوانب تاثير هذا القيود هو ان المواطنين
الامريكيين سايمنعون من العمل مع شركات
صينيه تصنع هذا رقائق
منخرطه في هذا المجال اذا
راينا الكثير من الاشخاص اضطروا الى ان
يوضحوا حقائبهم ويغادروا الصين وهذا فعلا
يؤثر على الصين بالاضافه طبعا الى ان انه
بالرغم من ان الصين لديها قدره وصول الى
هذه الالات كما فعلت من قبل بالرغم من
القيود فهذا يعني ان الان صار ذلك الامر
اصعب عليها شكرا جزيلا لك من لندن ذاك
مايرز كبير الباحثين في مركز الاصلاح
الاوروبي